I want to be in this person's armpit
I cannot believe we're smelling shirts
that you've worn Oh girls why did you
pick that hard though I expect a
lumberjack who's like 38 to wear this it
smells straight-up like my grandfather's
deodorant yeah this is a grown-ass man
who's not afraid to smell a little
feminine this is nice
this smells sexy ooh this one smells
good you get when I get the other if my
boyfriend was wearing this I would just
like hang out in his arm pain going it's
not beachy I love you it smells like a
smell that when a guy puts on a new
shirt after after what she'll yeah oh
she went for it I like this one as well
this my jack this might be ax I think
this is and I'm okay with it this
reminds me of a very specific boyfriend
and I can't put a name on who it is but
it's like bringing me back to a college
relationships is that weird it just
smells like a freshly cleaned gym locker
room but like high-end high-end it's a
one swipe kind of guy he doesn't even
like brand just like one swipe dork this
one is a little bit more feminine I
think definitely it is slightly girly we
should probably why I like it cuz I like
girly deodorants wing room I think I
would get with this one I like it this
is for sure a simple day but like in a
good way not in a bad way there smells
international to me yeah
I'm really torn but I'm gonna go with B
I'm gonna go with B as well
oh the lag I wouldn't mind smelling
missile in daily basis I am cheap but I
like degree cool
Gillette mascots the one that smells
like aftershave yeah don't tell me it
expensive Robert I'm not a speed stick
woman degree I knew it Oh Joe what
really Joey you picked you left I'm just
glad it wasn't ex oh it's late I was
really nervous
it's act you uh that's why you broke up
with him cuz he wears acts I'm not mad
at act I am a tax anyone not even Eva
that was try know if your grandfather
hadn't worn it you wouldn't exist
oh that's what my grandfather literally
wears all sideways let's get one thing
clear right now if anybody comes up to
me smelling like any of these deodorants
that good they're good